>>Narrator: Once a quaint outpost
in the middle of nowhere, Las Vegas,
Nevada has become a
sprawling metropolis,
and its public school system
is still bursting at the seams.
>>Carlos: Clark County is the
sixth largest school district
in the United States.
We have approximately 270,000
students today, and we,
on the average, open
up a school a month.
It's kind of insane to be able
to keep up with the growth.
We have 6,000 people moving in
to the Las Vegas Valley a month,
from all over, and so
our big push is literacy.
>>Narrator: At C. P.
Squires elementary,
90 percent of incoming
students don't speak English.
For principal, Carol Lark,
literacy is paramount..
>>Carol: [Speaking in Spanish]
>>The only hope our Hispanic
youngsters have, I believe,
is to master English, and then
they will truly be bilingual.
I say to the parents, it's your
responsibility to teach them Spanish
in your home, and please do that.
And it's our responsibility
to teach them English,
and then they will have all
their world open to them.
And so I really believe that poverty
and second language are
absolutely not any excuse
for not teaching children to read.
>>All: A, B, Cs and counting, one--
>>Narrator: Teachers here use a
variety of techniques to teach
and reinforce English
language skills,
from memorizing months
with The Macarena..
>>All: May, June, July,
August, September--
>>Narrator: To learning letters
with computer technology.
>>Computer: Find the balloon, T, T.
>>Carol: What I guaranteed
each teacher was
that if they would just
slow down their speech,
and teach everything
three different ways,
that these little five
year olds are like sponges,
and they will pick it up.
And the brain research
supports that dramatically.
The first year it was very
scary, because we weren't sure.
Now we're positive.
We know that it works, and
when they go into first grade,
we have 98 percent mastery
of all letters and sounds.
[Singing]
>>Teacher: What did you pick?
Baby animals.
>>Narrator: The school has received
several grants and partnered
with local business to create
innovative programs like this one,
where students get to take
home a new book each month.
>>Teacher: There you go,
that's yours to keep forever.
>>Narrator: There's also an annual
district wide storytelling festival
for fourth through seventh graders.
>>Student: She settled
it on the last one,
and then it was just
right, and then broke it.
>>Ardelle: Storytelling
is a way for kids
to sequence events in their head.
It also helps them to
develop sentence structure
and story structure, a
beginning, middle and end.
>>Student: She saw the
three bears and screamed,
and went running out the window.
>>Student: [Speaking in Spanish]
>>Narrator: Squires also promotes
literacy with after school programs
for preschoolers and their parents.
>>Teacher: Number one,
John is a student.
>>Carol: We knew we had to meet
the needs of the entire family.
So by working with the middle school
across the street, the parents go
across the street and get
English lessons, which is going
to enhance their future,
in terms of job potential.
>>Doctor: Here, put
this under your tongue.
>>Narrator: With the after
school programs, and the opening
of a new medical clinic on campus,
the school has become the heart
of the community, offering parents
and their children
everything from literacy..
>>Student: Stray cats are
often lonely without--
>>Narrator: To line dancing.
>>Leah: The biggest thing,
building self esteem.
They didn't think they'd
be able to perform.
First of all, they couldn't
even do the first dance.
They said, we can't do this.
Now they know three dances, we're
working on the cowboy hip hop.
>>Narrator: While grants pay
for many school programs,
private citizens have also stepped
forward to support their schools.
>>Announcer: Well,
howdy, boys and girls,
welcome to the McCaw's School Mine.
>>Narrator: Community volunteers
built and financed the School
Of Mines, and McCaw
Elementary School,
where visitors can explore
a replica of a silver mine.
>>Teacher: This is
the model of our mine.
You can see a chute going up.
>>Narrator: Tours in the school of
mines address curriculum standards
in history and earth science.
>>Student: It has all
these levels, called steps.
>>Narrator: And in hands on
activities like panning for gold--
>>Teacher: Pick up the pan,
let the ripples away from you.
>>Narrator: McCaw students teach
visitors about the science of mining.
>>Cheyann: Over here
are some little drills.
>>It's very interesting
that I get to talk to kids,
and I get to teach them
what they want to learn.
And they are always looking
at it, and talking about it,
and saying how cool it is.
>>Bill: I really think we
ought to mount it on something
that would look authentic.
>>Narrator: Local architect
Bill Snider,
volunteered to design the mine.
>>Bill: We went to Disneyland, and
we went to the, "Indiana Jones" ride,
where they created the illusion
of taking people down underground
and into a cave situation.
So we sort of figured out,
with the resources that we had,
what we could do, and it's kind
of funny, because the company
that built the, "Indiana Jones" ride,
actually did the work
here for us as well.
And what we did for them to do that,
we had several kids help us
write pleading letters to them,
and we took the model that we built
of this, and we set it in their lobby
for about a month, before they
said, "Okay, we surrender.
How can we help?"
>>Narrator: Other privately financed
learning environments include this
tropical biosphere at
Vandenberg Elementary School.
>>Teacher: What layer
of the rainforest do we
call that really high up?
>>Student: The canopy?
>>Teacher: The canopy, and the--
>>Narrator: But faced with
staggering construction costs,
and the lack of qualified classroom
teachers for every subject,
the district has decided to beef
up its virtual infrastructure.
>>Teacher: Let's do a sound check
real quick, and if it's all right,
then we'll go ahead and get started.
>>Narrator: In Clark County,
more than 4,500 students take
online courses in everything
from English One, to
AP Micro Economics.
>>Jhone: The Clark
County School District has
about 15,000 new students every year.
If we provide education at a
distance, the student can be
in their home learning
without us providing a brick
and mortar four walls building.
>>Teacher: Oh, Alyssa said no.
What do you think, Alyssa?
>>Alyssa: I would think maybe 50.
>>Teacher: Okay.
>>Jhone: Online curriculum allows
the student, if they have a question,
to go ahead and e-mail the teacher
right then, and not wait their turn
as you do in a regular
classroom, so the teachers
and the students both feel
that there's more communication
in an online classroom when they're
not physically sitting together,
than they do in a face-to-face
classroom
with a teacher and 35 students.
>>Teacher: You have the
full period to do this.
>>Narrator: Like many of his students
math teacher Mike Patterson now
splits his instruction time between
real classrooms and virtual ones.
>>Mike: The particular design of
this distance learning program,
made me feel like I was still
teaching, that I was still a part
of the classroom experience.
Students, they log in, I'm able
to interact on a live whiteboard
with the students, they raise their
hand, and I see them in front of me.
We speak through the mic.
>>If you look at your work,
see if you should have been adding
instead of multiplying them.
>>I want them to get as much as
they can of a classroom, but online.
>>Narrator: Giving
students the flexibility
of scheduling courses online,
also addresses another district
challenge, a high dropout rate.
>>Carlos: Las Vegas is different
than anywhere I've ever been,
because think about it, if you drop
out of school here, people have jobs.
And just think, you
can earn between 40
to 80,000 dollars parking cars here.
>>Joe: Okay, have a good night.
>>Carlos: So it's a
very unique situation.
>>Joe: I think I can make up to 130
dollars a night on the weekends,
maybe, and it's real easy,
because you don't need the
education to make the money.
>>Narrator: Now Joe Patterna can
pursue his high school diploma
and keep his night job, thanks to
a unique high school that caters
to students who have
dropped out in the past.
>>Kay: We have kids that work
early morning construction,
we have kids that work late night
at casinos, and so the high school
that goes from two in the
afternoon to nine o'clock
in the evening is perfect
for these kids.
They don't have to
give up their education
if they need money,
and they need a job.
We have a day nursery with our
school, which allows the mother
and the father to come to
school and have their child
on campus and safely cared for.
>>Student: Does this have
anything to do with the negative
and the positive, when
you've got to find the--
>>Teacher: Sure does.
>>Kay: I'd say the one thing
that is common about all
of our students is they're
very graduation focused.
They want to graduate,
they want to be successful.
>>Narrator: Success for the Clark
County School District means
overcoming illiteracy,
stemming the dropout rate,
and addressing the needs of
15,000 new students each year.
The key, says, Garcia,
is embracing change.
>>Carlos: We have an advantage
over everyone in this country,
because with the growth,
everybody expects change.
You don't need a rearview mirror
when you're going the speed of light.
And here, we're going
the speed of light.
We're always building, we always
have to train people, hire people.
Our cup is not empty, it's
overflowing with good things.
Can we still improve?
Absolutely.
And I think that educators have to
be critical of our own practices,
and we can adapt programs
and be at the head of it,
and instead of reacting, pro-act
to create things for the future,
and boy, you can't beat that.
It doesn't get any more
exciting than that right now.
>>Narrator: For more information on,
What Works in Public
Education, go to edutopia.org.